virtual unwrapping Begins by acquiring a
three-dimensional volumetric scan of the
damaged manuscript this scan produces a
set of cross-sectional images that show
the internal structure of the
scroll when viewed as a 3D object one
can clearly see the individual layers of
the scroll but any text on the surface
of those layers is obscured from view in
order for a readable version of the
scroll to be produced these images must
be passed through our virtual unwrapping
pipeline
first we capture the 3D Shape of the
layers of the scroll in a process called
segmentation on the left side of the
screen the software moves through the
scroll image by image tracing the shape
of a single scroll wrap on the right we
see the 3D model that this produces next
we extract the ink from the data in a
process called texturing using the 3D
Shape generated by segmentation our
software makes another pass through the
scroll this time looking for very bright
pixels bright pixels indicate regions of
dense material in this case inks made
with iron or lead we now have a single
wrap of the scroll with a text shown
clearly on its surface however because
the surface is curved it's difficult to
read all of the text from one Viewpoint
the flattening stage of our pipeline
converts this textured 3D surface into a
flat plane so that the text can be more
easily read to produce the best results
these three steps must be performed on
one small section of the scroll at a
time as a result we end up with several
texture images that must be merged
together this merging process creates a
single Consolidated image that shows the
full text using this pipeline we have
restored and revealed the text of five
complete wraps of the netti scroll the
two distinct Columns of Hebrew writing
reveal the scroll to be the Book of
Leviticus this marks the netti scroll as
the earliest copy of a pental book ever
found in a holy Ark a significant
Discovery in Biblical Art
archaeology